bei 21 hallo ich in meine lieben freunde
und herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren folge feed the beast zumindest
nicht so ganz weil wir nicht mal ganz
kurz f5 drücken und mich hier kurzum
blicke seht ihr schon was ist dass simon
weiß was hier passiert ist
ich muss gucken dass sie taktisch aus
da hätten wir doch glatt die kinnlade
runter du was ist hier passiert das
sieht ja so aus als wären da so ganz
schlaue leute auf den server kommen da
sie die alpinen im letzten video gesehen
haben und da diese zwei noch schlaueren
leute die das hier aufnehmen irgendwie
keine wald ist drauf gepackt haben wird
dieser server scheinbar gekriegt als das
wäre meine idee meine idee wer
eigentlich dass wir nach der letzten
aufnahme einfach mal fett scheißen
mussten
das ist dass ich bin heute morgen auf
die server gekommen und ich dachte hey
komm sie man nehme eine runde aufnehmen
und ja das haben wir nicht vor gefunden
sie waren noch leute auf dem server
drauf hab ich dann erstmal gebannt wir
wollen jetzt nicht allzu viel rum hätten
das war natürlich auch einerseits
unserer fehler das video ist nicht
aktiviert haben ja aber braucht ihr
fehler der leute egal ist
natürlich könnt ihr den kommentar jetzt
schreiben ihr idioten warum macht ihr
keine weit ist auf aber warum müssen es
immer okay wir haben so viele abonnenten
da sind immer ein paar schwarze schafe
dabei klar warum müssen wirklich leute
auf dem server kommen und dann das
ausnutzen wenn man schon mal so ein
fehler machte die app zeigt da und es
hat auch keine kommentare geschrieben
die auch traurig ich habe nicht erkannt
was mir nie konnten die ganze zeit
geschrieben wurde
warum wird klopp der sich bei dir so
scheiße an das war einfach der fehler
weil ich in skype das falsche micro
ausgewählt habe und deswegen waren wir
so am rätseln weil bei mir war die
aufnahme okay weil ich nehme ja mit
einer city auf und da habe ich meine
cross gewählt in skype allerdings nicht
dass man so doof einfach ein mikro und
deswegen heute kongresses gestern und
vorgestern die folgen bei mir richtig
mit hall und so an
jetzt hat der kongress wieder gut
angehört sei auf jeden fall war ganz
schön mein name ist eingespielt und ihr
seht jetzt eine weitere folgt
nein wir sehen heute kein pvp wir sehen
einfach 90 steuerten vize bi server ist
natürlich sehr traurig allerdings haben
wir also dass eine spinne wir haben uns
gedacht wir hatten einen wenn man es den
kompletten tag beziehungsweise simon
eigentlich hauptsächlich nachgedacht wie
wir das ganze ein bisschen auffrischen
könnten bzw
wenn wir so weitermachen würden dann
wäre es nichts ganzes und nicht nichts
halbes nichts ganzes und vergehen wir
mal an dich das wort weil es mir selber
schon erklärt hat seinen ganzen ja also
wir haben uns sehr viele gedanken
gemacht ich habe kontakt zwischen arzt
und jetzt seid ihr an der reihe
wir haben uns natürlich gedacht hey ja
wir haben kein wehren kein wiener
massenspeicher hat gespeichert hier das
gesäß save the world 11 nehmt gibt ein
richtiges wort für die fälle
wir haben jetzt nicht gespeichert so
also wir haben keinen der backup genauer
kraft genau wie ja ja wir haben ja kein
backup so was heißt unsere tun und alles
sind zerstört hier unsere zukunft
aufzustellen
also alles ist eigentlich was wir bis
jetzt gesagt haben sie stört man muss
dazu sagen okay wir haben jetzt nicht
die mega sachen gesagt weil wir sind
jetzt eigentlich relativ einfachen
langen deswegen wo ich sagen ich fühle
mich jetzt nicht so also die leute die
ihr spaß hatten wenn diese was drauf
einbilden hier leute uns könnt ihr mit
nichtstun
denn um so geil wird das was wir jetzt
vorhaben
hier kann ich sagen wir machen jetzt
einfach zu tun unterwegs gewesen das
geht nicht so und komplett neu anfangen
wer natürlich auch blöd wir haben uns
überlegt wir machen etwas noch nie
dagewesenes haben die ganze woche
überlegt und wir sind auf die idee
kommen ein wirklich hammergeil projekt
zu starten
und was ist genau ist wollen wir nicht
verraten weil das dauert noch ich sag
mal ein auf eine woche auf 2 ich werde
ich keine grobe zeit sagen weil es
dauert noch ein bisschen frau wird mich
in epischen trailer geben es wird ein
intro neues intro dafür geben es wird
ein bisschen vorbereitungszeit geben die
server einzurichten
es wird es wird episch es wird etwas so
lang wie das ding was kommt oft gepostet
etwas was ihr in minecraft und auf
youtube lage wie mein ding noch nie
gehabt weder von einem amerikanischen
youtube noch von deutschen also wirklich
ich sage euch da wird auch drauf kommen
trotz neun kommentaren streit
raten was wir vorhaben und business
startet also es wird also ich sage ich
bin ich sage euch gewählt werden die
welt so richtig darauf werden wenn es
einmal gesehen habt aber des staates
haben wir überlegt was machen wir zur
überbrückung und ja wir sind natürlich
nicht so wenn irgendwas ausfällt als
dann irgendwas als ersatz kommt ein
schlechteres sondern wir bringen jetzt
noch mal dass das beste was wir zu
bieten haben
bei uns wird es jetzt die nächste zeit
bis das neue projekt startet jeden abend
als ersatz die ungarn haben
wahrscheinlich für optische von spam fix
vielleicht kennt das wird so nicht das
heißt wenn ihr die schau erkennt so wird
es nicht beim name ist aber nach jetzt
nicht drei spiele von anlass und dann
sondern wir machen es folgendermaßen ihr
entscheid mit ihr schreibt jedes mal in
die kommentare
was wir als nächstes in richtung papier
machen sollen und wir zocken dann
zusammen die alle möglichst pvp maps pvp
modi was auch immer und ja es wird an
jeden amt kommt mit doll face camp das
heißt konkret wird mit facebook auf
nämlich für die festigung aufnehmen wie
gewohnt
und dann könnt ihr auch kommt oft das
schöne frisur immer sehen jeden abend
ein friseurtermin euro oder für euch
morgen auf unsere erste unsere erste und
computer
ja also noch mal kurz als
zusammenfassung was ist jetzt das leider
wurde hier das rief deswegen wird es
jetzt umstieg geben auf die
unkomplizierte show die nächste zeit bis
das neue projekt startet unter übergangs
projekt ich sag mal es sind nicht nur
die beide beim neuen projekt über wird
auch wenn noch alles dabei ist also ist
es ist ein paar gute leute sind dabei
und dazu gibt es einfach mehr infos wie
weit sich zu lang halten in meinem 12
stunden leistung am samstag dann
speichert auf das intro video auf einem
kanal also schreibe sie auch in kittel
info was passiert und bleibt also noch
mal ganz kurz ich werde noch mal alles
für leute die sich dafür interessieren
im zwölf stunden live zum ansprechen das
heißt ich werde von samstag ungefähr von
18 uhr bis 6 uhr morgens habe ich
richtig gerechnet ist von 18 06 12
stunden das sind die 16 stunden ja genau
also ich werde ungefähr ich glaube von 8
also ich hab mich noch mal vorher auf
twitter und facebook bekannt geben
ihr könnt schon mal auftritt auch
vorbeischauen ist als die beschreibung
aber jetzt auch nicht so viele eingaben
machen weil ich ja auch kontrastreiche
also zur stunde leicht informationen und
alles wichtig ist eigentlich gesagt es
gibt jetzt jeden abend willst du noch
einfach erzählen ja also es gibt jetzt
jeden abend um 19 uhr oder so roundabout
19 uhr diese unkompliziert wir halt
bestimmte sachen im pvp mäßig auf
servern des klägers kann dann zum
beispiel mit robin meinelt sein kann
dass wir beide games ein kamerad sein
da gibt es mittlerweile eine sehr große
bandbreite können allerdings denke ich
auch mal so manchmal mini-spiele sein
wie dieses vier gewinnt oder so haben
wir gemacht so etwas in die richtung
müssen einfach schauen wie wir das
machen wir können uns dann natürlich
auch sachen in die kommentare schreiben
und danach wird dann diese dieses
geheime projekt starten wo von simon
grad schon geredet hat und da könnte
jetzt einfach mal die kommentare
schreiben was ihr denkt was das wird wer
dabei sein wird und so was alles also
könnt ihr einfach mal so in die
kommentare schreiben dass jeder so was
euch dazu einfällt
es wird das megaprojekt es wird dass ich
sage euch ich habe eine skype konto
eröffnet und die heißt mega projekt
geheim
ja es wird aus ich sage euch nicht wer
da drin ist aber ich sage euch es sind
leute drin mit so penissen mit das sind
so lange peene leute und wenn ihr bis
jetzt also ok viele regal welchen penis
er bisher auf you tube gesehen habe das
sind die längsten penis hat so ein
abschied ohne wird ohne witz also leute
das war's intro video das ist ganz
wichtig alle leute in eurem
freundeskreis die auch die das vierte
play gucken bitte weiter erzählen oder
die allgemein minecraft gucken erzählt
dass hier das gestartet erzählt es
weiter und jetzt eure oma erzählt eurer
kcc teurer lehrerin eurer leere netz
wichtig aber die muss der schule auch
den kindern beibringen was richtig ist
und was falsch und bei uns gibt es nur
die richtigen sachen zu sehen
die richtigen penisse so leute wenn ihr
mit ihr gehabt schreibt einfach mega
projekte die kommentare
mit dem komplett mit euren ideen unter
einer mega projekt mit eurem lieblings
mailänder ich möchte alles was ihn mit
zum richtig hat man wirklich eure
lieblings mileys also megaprojekten
dahinter so ein richtig fetten smiley so
richtig schön sein lieblings mal die
annehmen falls ja also ich würde sagen
ich freue mich jetzt auf die nächsten
auf die nächsten 10 pp abenden
vielleicht letzte so ein bisschen so wie
elton wildes simon
genau wir können das unternehmen gelten
man ist immer so gegen dabei da ja und
wie ich wirklich bin für den kongo ist
irgendwann der arme könnte jetzt traut
hallo es ist sehr traurig für dich okay
wie könnte man die kommentare schon dass
ihr euch am meisten wünscht aber
vergesst nicht eure lieblingsband das
megaprojekt hinterlands fängt gut
leuchtet ich würde sagen alles ist
gesagt jetzt halt auch nicht traurig das
ist jetzt mit witali ist erst mal kurz
aufhört ist freut euch einfach auf das
mega projekt sondern ich bin der hölle
das hab ich verdient ach so warten in
der hölle wollte ich auch mal einige
haben auch leute zum portal gebaut würde
ich mal sehen was sie da noch alle macht
das futter haben wir gleich geworden ist
ein upgrade in benötigt diese sind wie
bei einer hölle
ich würde einfach mal sagen wir haben
einfach alles in diesem test geschafft
wir haben sogar die hölle erreicht
werden die andere welt erreicht wenn ich
jetzt noch diesen wenn ich jetzt auch
diesen gasquet besiegelt habe ich alle
mal zahlreiche fiel zunächst ja okay
also morgen abend geht es dann schon los
es gibt hier keine lücken
hier gibt es die geballte unterhaltungs
power und schreibt einfach was ihr euch
wünscht ihr könnt jetzt schon eure tipps
abgeben
sie werden gelesen also also ihr könnt
ihr eure wünsche was ihr euch wünscht
und wenn ich den kontrasten soll richtig
fest dann schreibt es auch und wenn er
mich wissen soll dann schreibt sie aber
nicht weil damit macht ihr eine unnötige
offen damit jeder genug gequatscht
ihr wisst jetzt wahrscheinlich werden
auch in einer sekunde fassen können vize
bi server ist kaputt sich deswegen kurze
pause pvp schaue jeden abend 19 uhr
beiden kanälen mit facetime und bald
kommt richtig aber mit mäßige projekt in
einer zwei wochen jetzt hat sie ja
verstanden
vielen dank okay leute denkt dran die
trikots